trust it's an important part of healthy
relationships essential in fact however
the more I look around the more I see it
missing trust in our media feels at an
all-time low trust in our politicians
the same and when it comes to so-called
experts you've guessed it in many parts
the trust has gone we're in an age where
people don't know whatts or who to
believe
we're so-called project fear and fake
news has caused folk to be dismissive
and disconnect and where people now
prefer personality to substance and all
of this is a serious problem these are
crucial times for our country and they
must be handled with care the polarizing
language the self-serving agendas the
attacking people people for being stupid
the desire to create news just for
cliques it all seriously needs to stop
before our trust collapses completely
because when it does
there'll be no coming back I'm sure your
deadline trust is the important word
about about media organizations - are
they trusted certainly my experience of
having been in ITV BBC sky is that the
news organizations take that very
seriously that they take they are
obliged under the law to be balanced and
I think they take that very seriously
the problem is we're living in a world
where if President Trump calls
everything fake news cuz it doesn't suit
him are we gonna go the same route in
this country and if we do you're exactly
it's exactly right I mean we're almost
already there
well I still know that if I watch one of
the traditional news broadcasters that
there is a proper system within that
broadcaster that that that that is a
fair representation so you might think
that from an insider you think yes well
I remember when it was interesting when
I was going through the bust up I had at
the BBC 15 years ago or so the trust
figures for the BBC never
ordered the trust figures for Tony Blair
in the Labour government went like about
15 years ago yesterday I still think
those I'd like to see the figures for
the BBC now and I'd like to see them for
Scott but I suspect there are still
trusted the problem is of course the
numbers watching those services is
inevitably in decline and therefore
people are giving in news and the
greatest danger is that they start
getting news only from a news source
that supports what they believe so it
just reinforces their own position can I
bring in the trusted profession stats
because we've got the stats in terms of
what people think today so it's quite
interesting
nurses 94 percent to teachers 87 percent
priests 65 percent bankers 38 percent
you were talking about people not
trusting the media journalists 27% and
even worse for politicians 17 percent so
she's right yes listen bank as well so
on that note journalists 20 that is
shocking I didn't know that so yeah not
sure that's changed much over the years
well journalists have always been down
the bottom it is important to say that
you know where I have a show on LBC or
here all of us on the Skype broadcast
journalists some are held to a certain
standard with Ofcom that print
journalist may not be held to because
Ofcom doesn't currently regulate print
journalism and so that's important to
make a point and on that note I've got
an example so we will heard about my
story in what happened now this
particular scar in the forehead was
caused by what I've said over and again
in both to the police and and on record
to the media as by somebody who was
either wearing a signet ring or had a
key in his hand and so I was on LBC this
morning with Nick Nick Ferrari and a
certain newspaper decided to report I
can't mention their name so I won't but
they decided to report on my interview
they said radio host radio host majid
who has praised his lunders coming to
his aid after races TAC yes that's what
I did after races tapped by man armed
with ice pick yeah that's why little did
they get that from so that's we did you
guys know something I don't avoid diving
why in the hereafter because if I was
attacked by an ice pick I'd be dead they
in the end deleted that will but where
on earth would they have I don't even
know
alright ok so there's a major paper bomb
it's a hundreds of thousands of people
the MS center regulated by Ofcom and all
that sort of stuff em rightly so ok so
you know you'd like to think that they
are reporting although sometimes in a
slightly biased way this way or that way
perceived by the person watching it okay
they are regulated so you can assume
that they are having to tell the truth
to a point what we've got nowadays owes
is we've got the internet way so if you
don't like that you can just go and get
a thousand likes on something else as
long as you're getting likes from a same
group of people all hitting your likes
you start very quickly but it believe
you're the only person that's right
because you don't get a balanced
approach on the other very few people
only sort of mixing their own circles on
the internet and don't take stuff from
elsewhere Jesse so that whose hoaxes are
spreading online so what happens is when
these echo chambers and the confirmation
bias kicks in people that want to
believe us can repost it and amplify it
travels halfway around the world and
then before you know it it's revealed as
a lie but everyone's already heard the
lie and believed it and it's funny
because having lived in America I have
to say Michelle even though the stats
say that people don't trust journalism
and they certainly don't trust our
politicians having lived in the States
I really value the impartiality of our
media where in America it's all opinion
based it's much more like a game show
here at least you know that the big
broadcasters particularly those like you
said those that are regulated by Ofcom
have to remain impartial and that you
know that they have vetted and re vetted
a story before they actually report it
and I think we we really need to be
valued at and and also know how
important it is that we have that
because not every Western democracy has
that but I think why this is such a
serious issue to me it's like if you
look at where we are now with brexit
we're talking about no deals or whatever
you will see frontline front-page
stories from lectures a supermarket
chief's that are saying look if this is
a city if we have this situation you're
going to have you know no food no
medicines or this or that people don't
believe them so our wearing out the
children happens but we're in a
situation where we should look at you
know this person is achiever of a
Superman
he knows more than me and you and then
but people are not people are looking at
that going
that's just project fear and it's gonna
have real serious that's not this that's
sorry great two seconds this not what
this but that isn't this but dad no it's
not because joined up no but what it is
is because it's all become about
identity politics particularly where
breaks a is concerned it means that
anything that challenges whatever your
view is whether that's remain or leave
anything that challenges that straight
away you are suspicious of it now with
this stuff until it actually happens
that's when people BR I wish I'd
listened to that supermarket chief
during the brexit the whole referendum
debate let's just look at what Michael
Gove said because it says the same is
what you say arguing that we should get
out are concerned to ensure that the
working people of this country at last
get a fair deal I think the people in
this country have had enough of experts
with organization from acronym these
organizations with acronyms saying that
they know what is best in getting
consistently wrong this comes because
these new books these people are the
same ones who got consistently wrong
I mean well he's right why he's just
saying the woodies say yeah well yeah
and you kind of it both ways he's saying
we don't want to know about experts so
if we're not gonna have any experts do
we found really interesting sorry very
quickly I find really interesting is
he's now listening to the experts and
saying he doesn't want a heart breaks it
but surely someone's told him is no good
idea so why is he listening now what he
was saying on the way I interpret what
he's saying there is that ultimately you
people have you've just lost the trust
in these experts from the acronyms and
what happens is instead of trying to fix
that what people are doing is they look
at her she's so stupid she didn't even
give a supermarket cheap she's an idiot
idiot idiot so someone like me who has
actually got the balls to be honest
about the situation that we're in people
are coming back and going
stupid stupid snow is closed
sometimes I'm at this time and earlier
on last week what about on the BBC where
I said and I made the point that
actually people do not now believe these
experts are these two and I made the
same scenario Super Mike and all I got
online is that Michelle Jew brewery is
so stupid that she won't listen to a
supermarket chief now I've got news I am
not actually that stupid believe it or
not and when you swen you say it don't
bother me you can tell me I'm super
don't really care but lots and lots of
other people when they are constantly
told that because they're in the
situation you're stupid you're stupid
you're stupid that strengthens the
results very hard though to do something
about when you want to believe something
so at the moment people so want to
believe that there's no way that's true
people should be saying this is very
concerning that vast I'm swears of our
population and now not believing what
they've been told by the media by
trusted people by politicians how can we
resolve that because by telling them
they're stupid things are not going to
end well okay now we've already spoken
about the Labour Party earlier in the
show but we're going to return to it for
a straight talk of the week one of the
empties that left the party this week
English Yana Berger has faced some
pretty horrible anti-semitic abuse on
social media over the last few months
but her defiant response has earned her
admiration even from senior members of
her party that she's just left he is
Barry Gardner in the Commons on
Wednesday I want to speak specifically
about the disgraceful treatment of my
honourable friend the member for
Liverpool Wavertree
I regret deeply that she has left our
party IRA get most of all the
anti-semitic abuse that made her feel it
was necessary to do something I have not
always shared her political judgments
but she is a strong and principled woman
and a kind and loving person who has
been bullied by anti-semites to a point
that most of us would not have had the
strength to bear what a brave man for
that mr. Gardner you are our straight
talker
of the week and I just had to that what
a brave woman in terms of Luciana what
she's had to put up with it she is
shocking